bien mesdames et messieurs bonjour
heureux de vous accueillir dans cet
hémicycle
médicis
vous êtes nombreux
nous sommes à l'heure et je voudrais
vous présenter ce qui m'entoure
premier vice président du sénat roger
karoutchi sénateur des hauts-de-seine
qui a été ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement et donc qui
connaît bien la vie parlementaire il a
dans sa délégation les relations
internationales au sénat c'est quelque
chose de particulièrement actif les
relations internationales puisque un peu
plus d'une semaine ne recevions le
président de la knesset israélienne nous
allons recevoir cette semaine le
président du sénat de jordanie puis la
semaine d'après président du sénat
d'egypte sur des sujets vous imaginez
bien au moyen-orient qui sont des sujets
de tension des sujets énergétiques et
donc
il fait partie des huit vice président
mais comme premier vice président il a
cette responsabilité je suis entouré de
deux questeurs
premier questeur du sénat qu est ce qu
un questeur ils sont trois
philippe bas sénateur de la manche
qui a été lui aussi ministre mais en
charge des affaires sociales et de la
santé
il a d'ailleurs commencé s'il m'autorise
à le dire son engagement dans la vie
publique autour d'une très grande dame
madame simone veil
vincent capo-canellas l'huile questeur
il est sénateur de seine-saint-denis et
et deux questeurs y gère le sénat avec
un troisième questeur qui
obligatoirement
éteint dans un groupe de l'opposition
puisque la question c'est un collège
dans lequel il n'y a pas deux dominantes
majorité opposition ils ont la
responsabilité de gérer le sénat de
gérer les personnels de gérer le
quotidien du sénat et j'allais dire
d'assurer tout ce qui permet au sénat de
fonctionner
il y as au sénat aussi sont ici présents
des fonctionnaires
ça me permet de remercier à cet instant
tous les fonctionnaires qui vous
accueille aujourd'hui qui accueilleront
demain aurait pu remarquer il ya une
ambiance particulière ici et je pense
que vous avez le sentiment que vous
étiez accueillie et que les gens
n'étaient pas là uniquement pour tenir
la porte où vous indiquer le sens il est
profondément cette maison et j'en
profite pour les remercier donc vous
avez ici les deux secrétaires généraux
du sénat eric tavernier
secrétaire général du sénat qui est donc
au sommet des fonctionnaires du sénat et
marianne b secrétaire général de la
questure donc quand tout va bien au
sénat c'est grâce au président quand il
ya une difficulté c'est à marianne b que
je m'adresse c'est non on en profite
parce que dans la responsabilité de
l'ensemble des personnels puis vous
apercevez un officier général
qui est ici
j'en profite pour le dire en remerciant
aussi les personnels de la gendarmerie
nationale et de la garde républicaine
qui assure la sécurité au sénat et qu'il
assure d'une manière particulière qui va
me faire ma transition
c'est à dire nous sommes dans une
démocratie
principe de montesquieu les pouvoirs
sont séparé
entre le pouvoir exécutif donc le
gouvernement et le pouvoir
législatif
que nous représentons avec l'assemblée
nationale nous ne pouvons pas recevoir
d'injonction du pouvoir exécutif et vous
savez bien dans un certain nombre de
pays en a aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont des parlements et
parlementaires sont sous la surveillance
de l'exécutif ou sous des pressions
parfois
presque le force et l'autonomie est
assurée puisque le responsable de la
sécurité
c'est le président du sénat aidés par
les questeurs est assurée par un
officier général pour la sécurité
j'aurais remercié aussi y en a où donc
je vois là les surveillants du palais
qui assure cette fonction
ici qui m'apparaît extrêmement
importante si vous le voulez bien en
deux trois mots puis après on fait
questions réponses on se donne jusqu'à
16 heures 17h55
vous avez pu
visiter où vous allez continuer à
visiter le sénat vous avez dans vos
petits livres toute l'histoire du sénat
tout commence
avec marie de médicis et tous se
continue aujourd'hui et en fait nous
sommes une assemblée depuis que
bonaparte
sénat et l'a installée ici nous sommes
une assemblée dans un système
parlementaire
bicamérale c'est à dire qu'il y a deux
chambres l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat et depuis la révolution française
il n'y a eu que de très courtes périodes
où il n'y a eu qu'une seule chambre
jusqu en
1789 à 1795
il ya eu une assemblée et il y a eu sous
la pulsion de cette assemblée un moment
politique à la fois exceptionnel
au début c'est la fameuse déclaration
universelle
d'août 1789 il ya une période de grande
tension d'un pays qui s'est appelée la
terreur et voyant cela on a voulu avoir
cinq ans après une assemblée qui
stabilisent les pulsions d'une seule la
formule et nous avons eu à ce moment là
la création du conseil des anciens
conseils des anciens l'époque il fallait
plus de 40 ans même un peu plus que ça
pour être élu l'idée était tempérée les
députés par une deuxième assemblée
et depuis la révolution donc depuis 1795
il n'y a eu que deux périodes où il n'y
a eu qu'une seule assemblée
qu'à un moment formidable
d'espérance
on peut dire la révolution de 48 c'est
une révolution qui peut porter beaucoup
de bonheur une seule chambre
ça se termine par le coup d'état du
prince président qui va devenir napoléon
iii
deuxième moment où il n'y a qu'une seule
chambre
au début de la 4è république dans un
projet de constitution il est prévu
qu'une seule chambre
et en 46 des français refusent dans un
référendum qu'il n'y ait qu'une seule
chambre
et nous sommes donc dans un système
bicaméral inégale
sur toutes les lois
c'est l'assemblée nationale qui
après examen par les deux assemblées
en cas de désaccord
l'emportent sur nous
sauf sur les modifications
constitutionnelles
où le pouvoir est égal
naturellement depuis le mois de juin les
choses ont un peu changé puisqu'il n'ya
plus de majorité à l'assemblée nationale
et qui si nous avons une majorité et
donc paradoxalement ici il faut
d'ailleurs qu'on fasse attention par
rapport à la constitution
nous avons un pouvoir dont il faut user
avec sagesse dans l'intérêt du pays mais
qui est à pouvoir d'obtenir parfois la
décision parce que un mécanisme elle
s'appelle la commission mixte paritaire
on met sept députés et sept sénateurs
ensemble dans une pièce et il faut qu'il
trouve un accord sauf qu'aujourd'hui
l'accord passe automatiquement par une
majorité qui est issue dans lequel le
sénat est un élément strictement
indispensables si je vous raconte ça
c'est parce que nous sommes les élus
n'ont pas
le suffrage universel direct
mais du suffrage universel indirect
quand vous votez pour votre conseil
municipal vous allez voter pour les
électeurs des sénateurs
les électeurs des sénateurs s'est
essentiellement à 95% des gens issus des
conseils municipaux auxquels s'ajoutent
les députés les conseillers
départementaux
les conseillers régionaux et un certain
nombre de citoyens dans les grandes
villes qui sont désignés par les
conseillers municipaux
c'est donc d'accord depuis cinq cent
mille personnes qui nous lient au nom
des citoyens
c'est le seul cas dans notre
constitution et dans notre pays où le
vote est obligatoire
il n'y peut pour ne peut pas s'abstenir
on peut voter blanc mais on ne peut pas
ne pas aller voter pour les élections
sénatoriales
parce que le conseiller municipal ne
sait pas toujours mais il s'en aperçoit
quand il ya des élections sénatoriales
il a reçu mandat
des citoyens en se présentant conseil
municipal en étant élu est bien de les
représenter
pour l'élection nous sommes donc
un balancier stabilisateur des
institutions notre mission c'est faire
la loi
et la loi elle passe elle se prépare
dans les commissions
philippe barrât premier questeur a été
auparavant le président de la commission
des lois
il ya une commission des lois il ya une
commission des finances et à une
commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense et des forces armées
il ya une commission des affaires
sociales et grande importance dans les
questions de santé une commission des
finances une commission de la culture et
de l'éducation et une commission qui
s'occupe des affaires européennes voilà
comment nos commissions fonctionnent et
donc chaque texte est d'abord examiné en
commission mais nous ne faisons pas
examiné les textes du gouvernement
chaque sénateur peut proposer une loi ça
s'appelle une proposition
de loi et et les danses et un certain
nombre de conditions y sont liées aux
groupes politiques
examiné par le sénat
notre fonction de voter la loi est très
importante aussi avec la fonction de
contrôle du gouvernement
vous avez un peu entendu parler de la
commission de contrôle
sur les cabinets conseils
c'était au printemps dernier c'est le
sénat qui a mis le doigt sur un certain
nombre de choses dit va d'ailleurs donné
dans trois semaines à l'examen d'une
proposition de loi d'ailleurs
gouvernement n'y est pas défavorable sur
le principe c'est dire que le rôle d'une
assemblée comme la nôtre qui est
beaucoup plus indépendante des
formations politiques est aussi de dire
et de faire émerger ce qui nous apparaît
comme la vérité donc faire la loi
contrôler le gouvernement
tracer des prospectives je me permets de
le dire parce que je vais prendre
l'actualité nous sommes en train de
traverser une crise énergétique est sans
doute cette prise énergétique va avoir
des conséquences
encore plus importante cet automne et
cet hiver vous trouverez un certain
nombre de rapports du sénat et rapport
pas simplement de la commission mais de
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
qui depuis plusieurs années alerte sur
l'état de notre système de production
d'énergie notamment électrique et
notamment sur la question du nucléaire
et donc vous voyez que cette fonction
aussi d'anticipations de poser des
questions fait partie du scénario
j'ai trop parlé je vois que vient de
dépasser mes dix minutes réglementaires
donc monsieur karoutchi qui quand il
présidait la séance ne devrait me
rappeler aux règlements
c'est vrai je l'évoquais nous sommes
dans une situation politique celui-là
aussi avec mes collègues pour répondre à
toutes vos questions y compris
politiques
nous avons je dois le dire une fonction
un peu nouvelle qui est en train de
naître nous allons à partir du début
octobre commencé dans nos commission a
examiné le budget du pays
ici on peut pas faire le 49-3 c'est à
dire qu'on ne peut pas adopter
on ne peut pas adopter sans à vote ici
même si l'assemblée nationale dernier
mot mais nous pesons est donc ici on est
dans un état d'esprit
d'examiner l'ensemble des éléments du
budget c'est vrai nous sommes moins
dépendants nous appartenant à des
familles politiques mais senna cultive
une indépendance vais sourire autour de
moi une indépendance qui fait partie de
jallet dire de sa nature profonde depuis
la quatrième république
je voudrais dire que parfois le sénat
s'est interrogé
sur sa place et son utilité je veux dire
qu'aujourd'hui le sujet mme appareils
moins prégnant
mais je crois que dans le temps que nous
vivrons on est en train de retrouver ce
qui était à l'origine de la vème
république et par un système
présidentiel la vème république un
système d'équilibré
entre un exécutif et un président de la
république et un parlement et nous
retrouvons plus de parlementarisme et le
sénat retrouver une place un peu
particulière depuis une décision je
parle a commenté aujourd'hui j'y ai
participé pas certain que c'était la
meilleure que j'ai prise c'est à dire de
réduire le mandat du président de la
république
ce qui a amené les députés à être élu
juste derrière le président de la
république alors que nous ne dépendons
pas de l'élection présidentielle nous
dépendons essentiellement des élections
il ya une alternance au sénat en 2011
c'est un président socialiste a été élu
parce que la majorité des conseils
municipaux en france et est à gauche
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas la même chose
mais la notion de gauche et de droite
elles existent ici mais par exemple il
ya un travail en commun qui se fait tous
les groupes ensemble et ça veut pas dire
qu'on est d'accord sur tout loin de là
mais on dialogue toujours les uns et les
autres voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
en vous souhaitant la bienvenue
et je réponds avec mes collègues parce
que la gérer cet après-midi du renfort à
l'époque du coc vite j'étais tout seul
masque est planqué mais je suis à votre
disposition pour répondre à toutes vos
questions et mes collègues alors c'est
pas très féminin la tribune
alors que nous sommes près de 40% de
collègues sénateurs femmes nous devions
avoir deux vice-présidentes avec nous
mais elles ont aussi des journées du
patrimoine dans leur département oui à
près de 40% de sénateurs qui sont femmes
c'est une évolution qui s'est faite au
travers de la loi et notamment d'une loi
qui a conduit à ce que les conseils
municipaux soient paritaire est donc
aujourd'hui
par exemple la vice présidente en charge
de la communication et valérie létard
sénatrice
sénatrice du nord qui a été ministre
pascale gruny
sénateur de l'aisne laurence rossignol
ne vous entendez parler très en pointe
sur les questions de société et qui ici
avec le questeur suis notamment les
questions de développement durable et et
les questions environnementales
si bien que chaque sénateur peut avoir
sa carte de coût carbone y compris dans
les transports depuis maintenant sept
années
parce que nous avons pensé que c'était
bien de voter des textes d'avoir des
discours mais il faut qu'on se
l'appliquent aussi à nous mêmes et
d'ailleurs les questeurs m'ont préparé
un système frugal moi qui ne me gêne pas
parce que je n'allume jamais de chauffe
dans mon bureau ce qui raccourcit les
audiences en hiver mais
ça va être comme ça dans tous les
bureaux quasiment à partir du mois de 9
ans donc vous avez la parole où on vous
propose vous vous présenter on essaye de
répondre on se partage des réponses
bien qu'ils commencent alors je sais
qu'il ya des argentins
comme argentina
yes yes je salue les argentins
particulièrement
ils sont mon espagnol étant trop limité
bien que mon gendre soit d'amérique du
sud
je leur souhaite la bienvenue c'est un
pays où il ya un sénat et je veux leur
dire aussi notre solidarité parce que ce
pays traverse un moment particulièrement
difficile avec une tentative
d'assassinât de celle qui préside le
sénat argentin aujourd'hui et quels que
soient les choix politiques
nous sommes je voulais leur exprimer ma
solidarité voilà bienvenue aux argentins
allez qui commence
voilà vais vous vous appuyez sur le
micro
bonjour vous présenter voilà
bonjour déjà merci de nous accueillir
aujourd'hui
j'avais une caisse à hamza sadaoui je
suis marocain santé j'avais juste une
question j'ai compris qu'il y avait une
commission des affaires étrangères je
voulais oui bonjour
[Musique]
j'ai compris qu'il y avait une
commission des affaires étrangères je
voulais comprendre en fait dans quel
sens on fait le sénat avait un regard
sur la politique étrangère de la france
et ce qui est ce qu'ils avaient fait ce
qu'ils ont en fait une influence sur les
décisions en fait l'examen du pouvoir
exécutif en fait sur les directives ou
des directions en fait que payer peut
prendre je vais demander à roger
karoutchi qui a en charge des relations
internationales qui a en charge aussi la
gestion de relation particulière qu'on
appelle des groupes d'amitié qui sont
pas des amicales de copains mais qui
joue un rôle pour vous dire que
il ya des sujets particulièrement aigu
sur lequel nous travaillons que ce soit
d'aussi est actuellement de la guerre en
ukraine par exemple
le sujet de ce qui se passe entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
nous aurons sans doute une proposition
de résolution dans les jours à venir je
laisse roger karoutchi vous répondre
merci monsieur le président il ya en
réalité deux axes d'un de réponse à la
question qui est posée premier axe il ya
une diplomatie parlementaire je veux
dire par là il ya des groupes d'amitié
ici du sénat avec pratiquement la
totalité des pays étrangers et ses
groupes d'amitié comme d'ailleurs le
président du sénat ont évidemment des
relations avec leurs correspondances
sénat ou assemblée nationale des pays
étrangers nous avons un suivi régulier
de nos activités le président recevra la
semaine prochaine le président du sénat
jordanien puis le président du sénat
égyptien nous avons su le président de
la knesset
nous recevrons d'autres présidents nous
avons reçu des chefs d'état le président
finlandais le président égyptien enfin
il ya une diplomatie si je puis dire
quasiment relationnel d'ailleurs puisque
vous parlez du maroc que voilà
nous avons fait ici un colloque sur les
accords d'abraham nous avons fait un
certain nombre de travaux et nous sommes
en partenariat avec la chambre des
représentants du maroc avec qui nous
avons non seulement un partenariat mais
un cycle de formation de manière à ce
que l'ensemble des pays avec qui nous
travaillons avance dans le cadre d'une
démocratie parlementaire ça c'est le
travail si je puis dire de la diplomatie
parlementaire du sénat et puis il ya le
deuxième axe qui est l' axe comme dans
tous les sujets gouvernementaux il ya un
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement par
la commission comme par l'ensemble du
sénat
par la commission eh bien les ministres
des affaires étrangères le ministre de
la défense sont auditionnés
régulièrement les budgets de la défense
les budgets des affaires étrangères sont
étudiées amende et validée par nos
commissions et par l'ensemble du sénat
ensuite et puis au travers des questions
d'actualité comme au travers de certains
textes quand on fait voter le livre
blanc pour la défense il ya évidemment
l'influencent du sénat dans les crédits
militaires quand on fait voter les
crédits du quai d'orsay il yal influence
du sénat parce que nous attendons des
textes et nous définissons les crédits
de l'ensemble de la politique étrangère
de la france donc il ya à la fois une
politique étrangère une politique
diplomatique conduite par le président
du sénat ils sénat tout entier par
rapport à nos correspondants
parlementaire et le contrôle de
l'ensemble du sénat sur l'activité de
défense ou de l'activité internationale
avant passer à la deuxième question deux
exemples d'actualité
le président de la république
finlandaise
est venue de rencontrer l'intérieur
rencontrer roger karoutchi
pour nous parler de l'adhésion de la
finlande à l'organisation du traité de
l'atlantique nord
nous étions à un moment du début de la
tension avec la russie onu créé et il
est venu lui qui avait toujours été
hostile
et qui voulait la neutralité de la
finlande il est venu nous rencontrer
parce que naturellement il faut le vote
mais il y avait une forme de maturation
des esprits
deuxième des choses
au début juillet je me suis rendu à kiev
je me suis exprimé devant le parlement
ukrainien qui s'appelle la rada
et radha est formé de quatre cent trente
députés plus de 400 étaient présents
mais en même temps nous avons même si la
période étendue nous n'avons pas coupé
les relations avec avec la le conseil de
la fédération de russie parce qu'à un
moment dans la vie il faut toujours
parler et le rôle une assemblée comme la
nôtre c'est de reparler et on n'ignorait
pas contre le maroc a parfois des
difficultés à nous parlons et nous avons
d'excellentes relations avec la chambre
des représentants mais je parle aussi
avec le président de la conseil de la
nation algérienne c'est le rôle de la
france
et donc c'est notre mission particulière
et là on est moins dans l'attention que
l'exécutif on peut se permettre des
choses qu'un gouvernement ne peut pas
faire
un mot le rôle du président du sénat et
du sénat d'ailleurs en général a été
considérable pendant la présidence
française de l'union européenne qui
s'est terminée au 30 juin et plusieurs
des réunions de l'ensemble des
parlements d'europe voire de l'ensemble
des commissaires européens ces réunions
se sont tenues au sénat sous la
présidence du président du sénat
d'autres questions
madame
merci beaucoup c'est bon oui merci
beaucoup donc je m'appelle rebecca je
lis je viens de suisse il trouve qu'en
suisse je suis aussi parlementaire dans
mon canton donc dans un niveau
infranational leurs collègues
ensuite on a aussi un bicamérisme mais
il est parfait c'est à dire que les deux
chambres ont exactement les mêmes
compétences et du coup je me demandais
en tant qu'observatrice externe 6,7
cette imperfection du bicamérisme donc
ce le fait que l'assemblée nationale
potentiellement pouvait avoir le dernier
mot qu'est ce que ça pouvait impliquer
comme tensions entre les deux chambres
comment est-ce que les relations du
compte les deux chambres se construisait
là autour je vais demander à l'ancien
président de la commission des lois qui
en même temps à l'expérience d'avoir été
ministre et qui a aussi je vous le dis
était le secrétaire général de l'elysée
philippe bas donc il a une expérience à
plusieurs niveaux de vous répondre en
est heureux de vous accueillir nous
avons d'excellentes relations avec le
conseil d etat nous oui c'est vous êtes
au conseil des états dans le canton vous
serez bientôt conseil d etat bien
évidemment donc nous avons d'excellentes
relations
alors chers collègues vous me posez une
question tout de même assez compliqué
mais tata cinq minutes pour répondre
mais mais
bon je vais essayer
notre bicamérisme
si il conduisait avoir deux chambres
absolument identiques ne servirait plus
à rien
nous avons donc deux chambres très
différentes
il y en a une autre qui représente les
territoires et qui est en quelque sorte
permanente parce qu'elle est renouvelé
par moitié tous les trois ans et elle ne
dépend pas du rythme des élections
présidentielle et législatives chambre
permanente chambre des territoires cette
chambre ne peut pas être dissoute
puisqu'elle est permanente explique la
dissolution c'est à dire que le
président de la république ne peut pas
renvoyer les sénateurs devant leurs
électeurs s'il ya un conflit
c'est une chambre qui ne peut pas être
non plus une chambre d'obstruction
car si elle dit toujours non alors le
dernier mot sera systématiquement donné
à l'assemblée nationale et donc c'est
une chambre qui a en quelque sorte dans
ses gènes l'esprit de
construction et de dialogue et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous tenons à notre
bicamérisme dont le président larcher
disais tout à l'heure qu'il est inégal
il est inégal d'une certaine façon en
effet mais nous ne le qualifions jamais
d'un parfait même si nous n'avons pas la
prétention de considérer qu'il est déjà
parfait il se rapproche progressivement
de cet objectif en tous les cas notre
originalité à nous c'est d'avoir un
petit peu de recul de distance par
rapport à l'événement l'actualité et
d'apporter une forme de pondération dans
la formation de la loi et une forme
d'indépendance dans le contrôle du
gouvernement
parce que on constater c'est pas la
faute des députés que quand nous avons
une majorité à l'assemblée nationale il
lui est très difficile d'aller jusqu'au
bout de ses pouvoirs de contrôle à
l'égard des gouvernements c'est pour ça
que dans la république le sénat français
n'est pas seulement un pouvoir c'est un
pouvoir puisqu'ils votent la loi mais
c'est aussi un contre-pouvoir puisque il
permet justement d'apporter un équilibre
dans nos institutions à 7 assez subtil
il arrive souvent que nous votions des
lois que nous n'aurions pas fait de la
même façon mais à partir du moment où
des choses importantes ont été mises
dans la loi par le sénat et où cette
fameuse commission mixte paritaire c'est
à dire la commission se rencontrent dans
une salle les députés et les sénateurs
pour trouver un accord à garder
suffisamment
des initiatives que le sénat juge
importante alors on va signer en bas du
parchemin on va dire oui cette loi nous
la voterons parce qu'elle a tenu compte
de ce que nous voulions mais pas
forcément parce que elle est exactement
comme nous aurions voulu qu'elle soit
voilà où nous pouvons uniquement dans la
république jouer un rôle réellement
constructif si nous étions dans un rôle
systématiquement
d'opposition à ce moment là nous ne
serviront plus à rien voilà 7 7 cette
inégalité entre l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat qui de notre point vue n'est
pas une imperfection
voilà j'espère que on a pu vous éclairer
et même comme le sénat est
majoritairement de la même sensibilité
etc l'assemblée nationale il ya toujours
une forme d'indépendance très très
grande ici se trouve que j'ai présidé le
sénat avec la même sensibilité
c'était nicolas sarkozy
ce que moi j'en suis à mon un bon
quatrième président de la république
mais
pas tout à fait 3 tous les cas
et bien le sénat avait sur des questions
par exemple de liberté fondamentale des
positions différentes de celles qui
étaient souhaitées
ici à une autre tradition que j'ai pas
encore dit c'est notre tension libertés
individuelles et collectives
je le dis devant philippe bas parce que
y compris pendant la pandémie de co vide
nous avons souhaité ne pas donner les
pleins pouvoirs à l'exécutif mais
toujours contrôlés et devront donner des
délais ont demandé à revenir devant nous
c'est vraiment la marque du sénat allez
une autre question alors vous et ensuite
dans les tribunes là haut allez-y
vous passerez vous avez eu là aussi
allez-y merci beaucoup je m'appelle
leona et je suis donc étudiants et
j'avais une question qui concerne le
fonctionnement de notre démocratie alors
que la france connaît une situation
politique inédite sous la vème
république avec vous l'avez dit monsieur
le président une assemblée nationale qui
est totalement morcelé sans majorité
absolue contrairement au sénat est ce
que vous pensez pas qu'il faille
renouveler nos pratiques démocratiques
le fonctionnement des institutions
politiques
pour pouvoir renouer du dialogue entre
les citoyens et re susciter la
participation au débat public et dans ce
cas là quel rôle le sénat peut-il jouer
dans la refondation de ces pratiques
politiques et en ce sens c'est ce que
vous pensez pas que l'initiative du
président de la république avec le
conseil national de la refondation soit
une bonne c'est un bon moyen pour
essayer de repenser notre démocratie
merci beaucoup alors sur ce sujet je
dois vous dire que nous sommes par
fonction la démocratie représentative
et philippe bas vient de rappeler avec
deux chambres différentes ça n'exclut
pas du tout la démocratie participative
et d'ailleurs nous avons introduit y
compris dans le fonctionnement du sénat
ou plutôt réintroduire revivifier ce qui
existait depuis la 3ème république donc
c'est pas une invention totalement en
d'hier c'est le droit de pétition et une
répétition c'est déjà appliquée
ici au sénat avec notamment un texte sur
l'allocation adulte handicapé dont le
gouvernement ne voulait pas et qui a
finalement été adopté après une
procédure
d'accompagnement notamment et sur les
allocations d'alu handicapés savez
traités là des gens des conjugale
isation cet essai le fruit de démocratie
mais
en 2021
le gouvernement d'alors nous a demandé
et proposer un texte qui soit
un texte qui permette l'organisation
d'un forum des consultations publiques
et ça a été donnée au conseil économique
social et environnemental
il ya donc une assemblée qui n'est pas
une assemblée parlementaire mais qui à
ce rôle de forum des consultations
publiques je reprends le texte de
l'attendu du projet de loi quand il nous
est présenté et c'est donc ce rôle de
d'organiser et par exemple je vais
prendre l'exemple de futurs débats sur
les questions d'éthique
des tic par rapport à la fin de vie il
va appartenir eux au conseil économique
social et environnemental
non pas dans des parts uniquement d'un
terme et il est prévu dans son
organisation qu'ils puissent constituer
constitué des panels de citoyens
voilà pourquoi je pense moi
personnellement que le conseil national
de la refondation réduit s'appuyer sur
le seul conseiller économique social et
environnemental
voilà pourquoi j'ai pris cette décision
parce que je suis très attentif on pas
ma gloire personnelle c'est pas le sujet
je suis très attentif à ce qu'on
respecte le parlement est qu on le
contourne pas et je ne parle pas dans la
conjoncture du président actuel il ya
toujours eu
notamment depuis 15 18 ans tentation de
contourner le parquet et je vais vous
prendre un exemple qui va nous faire
réfléchir tous puisque moi j'étais
parlementaire
sous françois mitterrand
jacques chirac
j'ai été parlementaire sous nicolas
sarkozy
sous françois hollande et j'étais
parlementaire avec emmanuel macron si
j'ai eu trois présidents j'ai eu 5 comme
parlementaire savais que j'étais élu le
même jour que jean luc mélenchon
il était le benjamin du cdh à moi le
fils benjamin je lui ai dit un jour tu
vois que j'ai plutôt mieux tourner que
toi mais ça c'est autre chose mais je
ça veut dire et je vois bien que depuis
j'y mets y compris des présidents que
j'ai soutenu il ya une tentation que
n'avait pas jacques chirac
de contourner le parlement derniers
exemples chiffrés
au cours du dernier quinquennat
plus il ya ulcos vide mais quand même
nous avons voté plus de la moitié de la
législation par ordonnance c'est à dire
que le gouvernement nous a demandé de ne
pas débattre au fond des textes est ce
que dans une démocratie l'otan peut le
gouverné que par ordonnance et par
ordonnance et par les petites sujet
c'est les gros sujets voilà pourquoi je
pense que nous vivons un nouveau temps
de la démocratie qui va redonner mais il
faut comme le disait philippe bas que
nous soyons responsables
le contre-pouvoir c'est vraiment notre
rôle et j'allais dire quel que soit le
pouvoir c'est vraiment notre fonction
voilà pour vous répondre
madame
à l'époque ah oui bonjour moi j'ai sur
yann je suis étudiante en master de
droit et je voulais vous demander que
selon vous qu'est ce qu'il y aurait à
améliorer dans le fonction du dans le
fonctionnement du sénat aujourd'hui je
vais donner la parole à vincent
capo-canellas ce qui est questeur mais
qui s'occupe aussi de beaucoup de sujets
de dossiers à la commission des finances
qui est en plus sur un sujet
développement durable grands
spécialistes hills
de l'aviation et de l'aviation civile
c'est normal il est dans un département
où c'est un sujet important mais
peut-être là une réflexion il appartient
au groupe de l'union centriste
donc je vous donne la parole merci
monsieur énorme merci moi je l'entends
votre question de deux façons qu'est ce
qu'il y aurait amélioré peut-être pour
rendre le sénat encore plus efficace et
pour faire que la démocratie
parlementaire soit plus efficace et soit
meilleur relais encore qu'elle ne les
séries dans les fonctions qui sont les
nôtres a notamment le contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement
nous avons un roc est essentiel qui est
parfois méconnus je vous invite
peut-être à regarder aussi les rapports
ils ont publié les auditions sur le site
du sénat ont fait beaucoup d'efforts
peut-être pour rendre publics tous les
travaux qui sont menés dans ses salles
de en particulier dans laquelle nous
interrogeons gouvernement de rendre des
comptes et nous lui demandons aussi de
se saisir de propositions qui remet
reviennent du terrain notamment les
collectivités locales qui sont pour nous
nos capteurs donc c'est sur le terrain
notamment du contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement là aussi le présent il a
rappelé on est à un moment quand même on
voit bien que l'abstention progresse et
que nos concitoyens ont parfois tendance
à se détourner de la politique en même
temps vous voyez bien quand vous
regardez malheureusement la guerre en
ukraine quand vous regardez la situation
dans le monde entier combien on peut pas
se désintéresser tout ça donc on fait
des efforts par exemple en train de
rénover le site internet du sénat le
président a parlé des plateformes de
pétitions et autres donc voilà notre
tout notre travail vise aussi à faire
qu'en gardant l'autonomie du parlement
en gardant l'oeil pendant ce qu'est la
note qui a été rappelé par mon collègue
philippe a notamment sur le mode
d'élection sur le fait qu' on n'est pas
dans le même temps que le temps
présidentiel
évidemment ce que nous essayons de faire
c'est de rendre les débats encore plus
vivant de mieux les faire partager
deuxième point pour ce qui concerne la
maison chennai même puisque le présent
bien vite et aussi nous sommes
nous aussi comme vous l'êtes et comme
les collectivités les entreprises de
sont dans les difficultés du moment
notamment ceux qui concernent la
sobriété énergétique nous y travaillons
le conseil de questure y travaillent et
le sénat a adopté il ya deux ans
maintenant une nouvelle vision de sa
stratégie environnementale voilà et donc
nous sommes sur une stratégie zéro
plastique
00 déchets plastiques à trois ans
maintenant et puis nous sommes sur une
stratégie
de sobriété total est de zéro émission
en 2040 voilà donc cette maison que vous
avez parcouru qui est aussi un site
patrimonial fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
être aussi exemplaire que possible
maintenant sur ce qu'elle coûte en terme
environnemental mais aussi en terme
financier on pourra en parler je sera
plomb que pendant 12 ans nous n'avons
pas augmenter la dotation qui nous est
versée par l'état c'est à dire même pas
l'inflation
et donc on a fait beaucoup d'efforts de
gestion qu'on va continuer bon voilà
senna encore plus efficaces du point de
vue des gars si la démocratie puis senna
aussi faisant encore plus d'efforts
qu'il n'en fait déjà aujourd'hui qui
sont considérables sur le thème de la
sobriété énergétique et financière
oui monsieur on va vous tendre le micro
voilà
merci bonjour monsieur le président je
suis antoine fontaine avocat à paris et
ma question concerne votre fonction à
vous en tant que président quel est
votre rôle exactement au sein
d'hémicycle à l'égard de vos collègues
et votre rôle avec le présent arrêt
public votre rôle finalement à l'égard
des autres institutions qu'est ce que
vous représentez
voilà merci manche et remettre
le rôle du président du sénat
c'est dans la constitution d'abord de
présider cette assemblée et donc
d'assurer
le fonctionnement l exercice de la
démocratie parlementaire
de permettre à tous les sénateurs qui
sont égaux de pouvoir s'exprimer
librement et qu'ils puissent exercer
j'allais dire l'ensemble des missions
qui sont les leurs
j'ai un rôle particulier puisque nous
sommes divisés en groupes politiques
chez nous diviser c'est simplement un
fractionnement s'est pas défaussé
de la gauche à la droite
de du groupe communiste hors europe les
républicains et quelques personnalités
indépendantes qui se situe plus à droite
pour la plupart d'entre elles ici un
groupe écologiste alors qu'il en avait
pas l'assemblée nationale jusqu'au mois
de juin ici il ya un groupe qui incarne
la république que historique de la
troisième un petit groupe radical et
iliad est un groupe socialiste
donc le groupe communiste le groupe
centriste
et le groupe l'est républicain
émond deux premiers devoirs ses dettes
j'allais dire très attentif aux
minorités et à l'opposition ici droite
parole est extrêmement égal au point
d'ailleurs que le plus grand groupe il
s'en plaint parfois
à moins de temps de parole dans les
questions au gouvernement que les plus
petits groupes mais nous avons pensé
collectivement et à l'unanimité
d'ailleurs sur une proposition à
l'époque du sénateur karoutchi et du
sénateur alain richard qui est
aujourd'hui vice-président du sénat et
qui appartient à la majorité
présidentielle
nous avons pensé qu'il fallait que nous
ayons cet équilibre là donc
assurer
un vote de loi qui soient équitables
justes
respectueux permettent l'expression
aussi des missions de contrôle et donner
les moyens de contrôler
seconds rôles du président du sénat
c'est bien sûr d'avoir des relations
avec le gouvernement
et
d'avoir des relations avec le
gouvernement est d'abord avec les
ministres et en premier chef la première
ministre j'ai d'ailleurs proposé la
presse une méthode de travail dans la
situation politique dans laquelle nous
sommes pour que nous anticipions sur les
textes non pas pour les co construire
ensemble chacun doit être dans son rôle
mais plutôt que de découvrir un texte au
sortir des conseils des ministres qu'on
en ait parlé avant qu'on se soit 10 vers
quelle direction
l'exécutif voulait aller quelle était la
direction et donc
je rencontre extrêmement régulièrement
la première ministre hier c'était à
vichy pour parler des régions mais pour
quelques temps nous allons faire comme
nous le faisons très régulièrement un
tour d'horizon et d'ailleurs les
sénateurs les présidents de commission
mais à porter ils ont des relations avec
les ministres et
la première ministre est responsable
devant nous
se connait pas le président de la
république le président de la république
à une autre fonction même si depuis la
réforme du quinquennat on est dans une
situation
où le président arbitre et - arbitre
qu'il n'était à l'époque du septennat
puisqu'à l'époque du septennat
regardez ce qui est arrivé à françois
mitterrand regardez ce qui est arrivé à
jacques chirac il a connu un
gouvernement de cohabitation
aujourd'hui c'est théoriquement possible
mais j'allais dire la situation est
telle qu'on peut s'en retrouver en
majorité relative mais qu'il serait
assez peu probable qu'on soit
naturellement gouvernement de
cohabitation on pourrait demain dans un
gouvernement de coalition
ce qui est tout à fait autre chose et
qui ne correspond pas l'histoire de la
vème république en tant que tel
ces patients en italie
par exemple serait assez difficile à
imaginer chez nous j'ai donc des
relations avec le président de la
république
qui
était irrégulière ils sont en train de
devenir régulière
parce que je pense que c'est l'intérêt
du pays que nous parlions et que nous
essayons de trouver un certain nombre de
choses il ya les sujets nationaux
il ya les sujets européens très
important
en effet roger karoutchi l'a rappelé
nous avons joué un rôle important au
moment de la présidence française de
l'union européenne parce que en plus
l'assemblée nationale était à un moment
de renouvellement et que nous avons eu
l'agression russe contre l'ukraine et
qui a fallu réagir sur un certain nombre
de sujets et qu'il est assez pour nous
facile de réunir les 27 parlement
européen nous avons ces relations là et
donc y compris en accord avec le
président de la république je n'ai pas
été à kiev semble coordonnée avec le
président de la république par exemple
parce que l'intérêt aujourd'hui de la
france de l'europe et de l'ukraine c'est
pas que chacun aille faire son petit
truc dans son coin c'est au contraire
que nous soyons complémentaires ça c'est
le fonctionnement d'un cinquième
république et j'ai naturellement des
relations avec aujourd'hui la présidente
de l'assemblée nationale là aussi
extrêmement régulière ne croyez pas il
n'y a pas de guerre de tranchées il peut
y avoir des différences mais ici tout en
l'étant contre-pouvoir c'est vraiment
l'intérêt du pays et pas bien dire ça
vous allez diriger tout le monde dit ça
mais honnêtement c'est ce qu'on cherche
ce qui parfois amène un président de
sénat où des présidents de groupe va
devoir expliquer à ses collègues y
compris dans son nez dans cet hémicycle
où se réunissent les deux groupes
politiques du sénat je rappelle que dans
leurs deux premiers gros pis si c'est
les républicains le deuxième c'est
groupe socialiste parce que les
socialistes demeurent extrêmement
important dans les mairies et chez les
élus locaux
pareil pour les républicains voilà deux
pas qui aujourd'hui sont minoritaires à
l'assemblée nationale et qui ont des
représentants et donc
nous avons ce dialogue qui m'apparaît
nécessaire comme j'avais les relations
avec richard ferrand et avant avec
claude bartolone c'est important et je
dois dire plus que jamais avec la
présidente de l'assemblée nationale
parce que roger karoutchi le disais
tout à l'heure mais philippe val a
résumé il faut bien qu'on trouve des
voies de sortie qui nous permettent
d'éviter d'aller de crise en crise
et c'est ce que nous faisons et puis
elle rôle constitutionnel que tout le
monde connaît
c'est la continuité de la république
qui est je l'espère s'appliquera jamais
mais qui s'est appliqué par deux fois et
qui venait d'une volonté du général de
gaulle
général de gaulle a demandé à michel
debré et à ce qu'on fait la constitution
d'un cinquième comment fait-on en cas de
crise grave
départ du président de la république
décès démission qui assure la continuité
de la république général de gaulle était
marqué
par la manière dont la troisième
république était morte à vichy
et comment après la démission du
président lebrun il n'y avait pas eu de
continuité et comment dans cette
situation la république c'était en
quelque sorte effacés et il avait dire
aux rédacteurs de la constitution
sous l'autorité de michel devrait
trouver une formule le roi est mort vive
le roi c'est à dire qu'il faut une
continuité
et c'est le rôle du président du sénat
c'est d'ailleurs dans un pays où le rôle
du président de la république n'a rien à
voir le rôle du président du bundesrat
allemand quand le président de la
république allemande c'est arrivé il n'y
a pas si longtemps que ça vient de plus
pouvoir exercer ses pouvoirs c'est le
président du bundesrat qui exerce les
fonctions de président de la république
fédérale d'allemagne particularité en
france ces quêtes président de la
république c'est avoir des pouvoirs très
important notamment en matière de
défense et de forces armées et le
président du sénat cotisation à
l'intérim a tous les pouvoirs le
président poète a exercé deux fois
après la démission du général de gaulle
et à la mort de georges pompidou et le
système je peux vous assuré il est
toujours prêt à fonctionner on a une
manière de fonctionner en toute
responsabilité
mais le seul veut c'est qu'ils ne ça
n'arrive jamais parce que ce serait soit
le signe d'un drame personnel soit le
site d'un drame politique c'est pour ça
que je citais l'assemblée de bordeaux
qui a été quand même en ne donnant pas
de suite il a ouvert à 1 au drame
historique qu'est l'état français
voilà
il nous reste sept minutes 8 minutes
pour une question
madame
parlez bien dans le micro ouais ça ça
marcherait isabelle mangin donc j'habite
à sarrebourg en moselle
ma question est la suivante en cas de
commission mixte paritaire comment sont
sélectionnés les sept sénateurs qui
défendront le sénat pour voter la loi
vous parle d'un spécialiste absolu de la
commission mixte paritaire parce que la
commission mixte paritaire c'est les
présidents de commissions qui joue un
rôle mais ça se fait pas sans règles il
va vous expliquer c'est tout simple en
fait si vous deviez l'inventent et
veulent inventorié peut-être comme ça
dans une commission du sénat il y à des
sénateurs de tous les groupes
il faut autant que possible que ces sept
sénateurs qu'on va envoyer pour discuter
avec sept députés soient représentatifs
de la diversité du sénat et donc on
calcule assez exactement combien de
sénateur membre de la commission mixte
paritaire chaque groupe qui représentait
à la commission
va
avoir pour respecter le poids respectif
de tous alors ça donne pour la majorité
sénatoriale
4 sur 7 ensuite il faut trouver les
trois autres or il y a plus de groupe
que trois dans les groupes minoritaires
alors on fait les choses gentiment à
tour de rôle en fait et voilà comment ça
fonctionne tout simplement
si un sujet très important et
c'est un des rôles du président du sénat
dans là on peut filmer la protection des
minorités de s'assurer qu'il n'y ait pas
d'abus et qui est ce respect
aussi bien en titulaire qu'on suppléant
est ce que oui parce qu'il faut
peut-être que tu ajoutes les suppléants
non invasive et le président le dit j'ai
oublié de j'ai omis de dire qu' il y a
sept suppléants ce qui permet finalement
à tous les groupes au moins même s'ils
ne votent pas tous à la commission c'est
que je parie blair
de s'exprimer et d'être témoin de ce qui
se passe ensuite ils pourront rendre
compte quand on va adopter le texte en
séance officiellement il ya personne
n'est exclu de ce travail en commission
mixte paritaire c'est maintenant que le
plus petit que le leur rappeler
une dernière question
madame
bonjour je m'appelle anna je suis
également étudiante en droit moi ma
question c'est comment est-ce que votre
rôle en tant que parlement national at
il évolué face au pouvoir grandissant on
peut dire législatif de l'union
européenne
monsieur karoutchi
non parce que c'est sa responsabilité
la chance il il a aussi été
dans sa jeune vie l'ambassadeur allou
ces dieux et parlementaires européens et
par le terreau des
cantons a tout fait on est revenu de
beaucoup de choses
alors
la question vous poser est elle n'est
pas récente en réalité sont les textes
qui ont donné beaucoup de pouvoir
peut-être trop mais beaucoup de pouvoirs
au parlement européen
en gros on considère qu'aujourd'hui 70 %
de ce qui est appliqué dans les pays de
l'union européenne vient en réalité ou
du parlement européen de la commission
européenne comment est ce que le pouvoir
évolué d'abord nous sommes extrêmement
attentif et sensible à la répartition
des pouvoirs
il est clair que
on a une tendance naturelle joue le
titre gentiment mc pas l'espagne
critique institutionnels le parlement
européen souhaite toujours plus de
pouvoir souhaite toujours comment dire
étendre sa capacité à agir et la
commission européenne a une tendance
naturelle à considérer que ces
directives doivent être appliquées
quasiment tel quel donc dans la pratique
le parlement français pas seulement le
sénat l'assemblée nationale
une commission des affaires européennes
qui contrôle et vérifie le fait que le
parlement européen la commission
européenne n'empiète pas sur les
pouvoirs des parlements nationaux donc
de ce côté là c'est extrêmement
tranché on a à plusieurs reprises et
lorsque philippe bas était président de
la commission des lois on l'a rappelé à
plusieurs reprises
le gouvernement français nous demandait
parfois de commandes il ya de sûr
transposer un certain nombre de
directives européennes et c'est sur
transposition réduisait d'autant la
capacité législatives de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat donc ici nous
refusons nous refusons les sur
transposition ou défendons la capacité
du sénat à agir dans le cadre de la
constitution mais à préserver l'ensemble
des pouvoirs tout simplement parce que
chacun en est conscient
les citoyens
sont de plus en plus sensibles au fait
d'être associé on l'a dit tout à l'heure
sur certaines instances qu'on voulait
créer le premier élément c'est de faire
en sorte que les citoyens se disent
notre parlement national a conservé
beaucoup de pouvoir parce que le jour où
tout sera européen alors très clairement
les citoyens se diront vive le conseil
national refondations donc c'est très
clair c'est au sénat c'est à l'assemblée
nationale que le pouvoir législatif
français doit être défendu appliquez pas
moins que la constitution pas plus que
la constitution avec toute l'amitié le
respect que nous avons pour le parlement
européen
allez une dernière question
monsieur
candé on arrive
bonjour un seul président théo marc
l'étudiant je voulais me poser la
question comment vous ressentez vous
expliquer le fait que le sénat soit
représentée majoritairement par les deux
partis traditionnels les républicains et
le groupe socialiste alors que dans le
même temps l'assemblée nationale se voit
à nouveau tripartie avec leur assemblée
nationale du ps
renaissance
quand on ressentez vous savez comment
analysez vous ce changement
je le disais tout à l'heure c'est parce
que nous sommes les élus
des élus municipaux essentiellement si
vous prenez les élections municipales
elles ont consacré dans le pays une
représentation qui est assez différente
et cette représentation assez
différentes c'est fait
j'allais dire autour de trois grands
courants politiques
le courant des républicains allié avec
avec les centristes qui représente dans
le pays un peu plus de 50% des élus
locaux auxquels s'ajoutent des élus
ruraux qui n'appartiennent à aucune
formation politique mais ça veut pas
dire qu'ils n'ont pas d'idées politiques
et qui sont dans un tempérament je le
dis devant un élu de la manche
profondément modérateur et est modéré et
qui rentre bien dans le balancier
stabilisateur des instituts
l'autre parti politique du pays est
incarné par trois forces politiques
dont l'essentiel dans les collectivités
est incarnée par
les socialistes et qui est une réalité
politique dans ce pays avec le soutien
des communistes il en reste dans ce pays
et qui d'ailleurs je parle qui sont
souvent des gens très je veux dire ici
très engagé particulièrement engagée en
responsabilité dans leur représentation
est maintenant un certain nombre d'élus
écologistes et d'ailleurs nous avons eu
des élus écologistes avant qu' il y ait
là nubes ici et donc je crois que c'est
la traduction
de cette diversité française et il y
avait la pulsion
mais je reviens en 1795
il y avait une assemblée qui exprime et
des pulsions et puis une assemblée qui
était de stabilisation nous verrons
prochaines municipales
mais nous verrons aussi l'an prochain
puisque nous sommes soumis à une
réélection
par exemple vincent capo-canellas ce
roger karoutchi et moi même et le
président bah nous sommes soumis à
réélection an prochain c'est à dire que
nous allons retourner devant les
électeurs et nous verrons s'ils nous
font confiance ou pas
dont il n'y a pas de difficulté saas
explique que je vais dire logiquement
en 2011 la majorité les conseils
municipaux
étaient à gauche y compris dans la
partie rurale
il était plus qu'aujourd'hui et c'est le
président bayle qui a été élu à ma place
nous avons vécu ça comme une alternance
j'allais dire qu'ils étaient logiques
pas vous dire que ça m'a fait un bonheur
absolu mais
nous avons vécu cinq plutôt comme une
chance pour la démocratie d'alternance
l'alternance c'est pas un drame dans une
démocratie quand on respecte les
principes qui ont guidé l'alternance
j'ai peut-être demander à vincent
capo-canellas ce de conclure avec son
regard parce que lui est un élu d'un
département urbain d'un département qui
connaît quand même beaucoup de
difficultés qui concentrent beaucoup des
difficultés françaises mais qu'ils
consentent rosiers un certain nombre
d'activités majeures est positive pour
notre pays le département de seine saint
denis pour vous dire que nous ne sommes
pas
que les héritiers d'une assemblée que
nous revendiquons puisqu'on disait c'est
l'assemblée du seigle et de la châtaigne
c'est vrai nous représentons les
territoires ruraux mais pas que les
territoires
roger karoutchi la ruralité
du côté nantais route sur aisne s'est
pas totalement la marque chez philippe
bas c'est une marque a pourtant lui la
chance d'être le sénateur ville saint
michel mais aussi de le p r cherbourg
mais aussi d'une modernité agricole dans
la qualité et moi je suis dans un
département les yvelines moitié-moitié
urbains industriels
universitaires et en même temps rural je
rappelle que le sud du département des
yvelines
c'est sur les chemins de peggy l'océan
des blés et donc voilà mais je voulais
que ça soit un urbain qui puisse
conclure parce que le sénat s'est aussi
beaucoup à départements urbains
merci monsieur le président merci à
toutes et à tous tâche difficile
d'essayer de de tirer des conclusions
ensemble ou de conclure moi ce que je
veux vraiment vous dire d'abord ça pour
plonger la question de monsieur c'est
que la grande différence aussi c'est le
mode d'élection
est d'ailleurs on l'a pas forcément
rappeler mais au delà trois sénateurs
nous sommes tous élus à la
proportionnelle ce qui permet d'ailleurs
avant ce que vous avez vu c'était cette
année à l'assemblée est un peu un
miracle parce qu'au scrutin majoritaire
n'a quasiment eu les résultats la
proportionnelle mais nous avons ici la
proportionnelle dans tous les
départements qui est lisse plus de trois
sénateurs c'est avec une expression de
la diversité est juste pour préciser les
choses 80% des sénateurs sont donc élus
à la proportionnelle et on avait
effectivement il y compris ici des élus
du front national à un moment donné où
l'assemblée n'avait pas clairement donc
voilà il ya aussi un point c'est que
nous ne découvrons pas l'élection
présidentielle parce qu'habituellement
les députés sont élus dans la foulée
l'élection présidentielle et c'est la
réplique donc grosso modo le président à
sa majorité là il ya eu un changement
cette année mais en tout cas c'était les
suites de la présidentielle avec ce que
vous indiquez cerdagne ps et le fn fort
dans la retrouver à l'assemblée voilà
sinon d'abord vous dire que le temps que
vous passez à visiter ces lieux ce sont
des lieux où le présent l'a rappelé on
travaille moi j'étais là hier ici avec
des députés et des sénateurs des
parlements européens sur les questions
spatiales
nous avons ici des auditions qui
concerne par exemple les prisons qui
concerne le fonctionnement de la justice
nous allons rentrer dans le débat
budgétaire nous sommes ici sur les
questions énergétiques
nous travaillons sur les affaires europe
les questions internationales et c'est
donc la démocratie est vivante et le
sénat est dans un système certes
inégalitaire mais qui nous donne une
vraie liberté la liberté qui est que
nous ne procédons pas de l'élection
présidentielle le président république
ne peut pas dissoudre cette assemblée et
un sénateur même s'il soutient
l'exécutif est totalement libre de dire
non je crois c'est une grande chance et
on vous l'a doit aussi on la doit à nos
pères et à cet état d'esprit que
ensemble vous le voyez le président les
vice présidents les questeurs on essaye
de faire vivre cette cela la démocratie
pour qu'elle vive elle suppose qu'ils
aient des moments de respiration et que
nous ne soyons pas tous alignés et le
sénat à cette grande chance c'est sa
liberté c'est à dire qu'il n'est pas une
institution à l'idée voilà donc merci en
tout cas de ce que vous nous avez invité
à
entendre à regarder aussi et puis à
votre disposition avec l'ensemble des
personnels qu'ils sont au service de la
démocratie aussi avec nous voilà on
espère que vous repartirez dans vos
territoires aussi avec l'envié aussi
peut-être de là de vous exprimer de vous
présenter ne pas hésiter à nous saisir
pour continuer les débats remercia tous
regardé notre site regardez pétitionner
mais pas trop
quand c'est nécessaire
vraiment regarder on est en train de
refondre complètement le site regarder
les chaînes parlementaires
il ya un problème aujourd'hui entre les
citoyens la vie politique mais je ne
connais pas dans la démocratie d'autres
manières que
de fonctionner dans des réalités
politiques à nous d'être aussi en
capacité d'être en proximité avec les
citoyens c'est sans doute ce qui
m'obsède le plus moi personnellement
aujourd'hui quand je vois le niveau
d'abstention au niveau d'expression qui
quittent l'alternance démocratique
je suis quand même inquiet résultat les
élections suédoises doit nous faire
réfléchir nous donne des responsabilités
et vous allez voir ce qui va se passer
en italie le dijon exprime avec ma
sensibilité
très attentif à la démocratie et aux
libertés
donc vraiment et vous avez certes visité
a lieu magnifique
formidablement entretenu vraiment on a
des équipes et je remercie les questeurs
car une ans nous avons une
responsabilité patrimoniale mais
puisqu'on parle de durabilité la
première durabilité ça doit être la
durabilité la démocratie et ça n'est
jamais a bien acquis in aeternam merci à
tous et bonne fin de visite
[Applaudissements]